might be one of the taller starting
lineups that ever with the ball might be
one of the taller starting lineups that
ever the 250 260 pounds maybe look
really really good well and a couple a
couple days ago coach Malone when they
scrimmage live in practice well coach
Malone was like okay look it's gonna be
sloppy it's gonna be messy but the
turnover outside of Zion there were some
rookies that had some really good
seasons and I he was one of them I'm
he's a he's a really good player for
them I know that they like his future
it's where the the number one field goal
percentage team over 50% number 13 out
of here throw field goal percentage team
so you know they were looking to make
strides in their field goal percentage
team over 50% on number 13 out of here
throw field goal percentage team so you
know they were looking to make strides
in that area the Nuggets have an early
lead over the Washington Wizards three
times the player that his dad was his
dad's gonna shoot like that I'll get out
yeah nine seven nine wingspan great
example right here look at this look at
that
well he wasn't even close to the player
and so you see the kind of ground he can
cover look how far away he has when he
jumps high so you know that Dad a few
days ago he said the one thing he's
discovered he's got to get his hands up
in the air and so I think those
but Roy Daniels has gotten some good
reviews in camp also these players and
coach you and now he's playing point
guard look at that Devon lay on offense
and defense Nuggets have been stuck on
32 since Hector was a pup well what once
was a double digit lead for the Nuggets
that they'd whittled down to three yeah
Millsap doing very well this season they
shoot free throws seventy seven and a
half percent it's their best free-throw
shooting percentage
Oh with the block in 30 years the
Washington Wizards but first a look at
what bull bull can do for you seventy
seven and a half percent it's their best
free-throw shooting percentage Oh with
the block in 30 years the Washington
Wizards but first a look at what bull
bull can do for you you can block for
you he can run the court for you and
then he doesn't even have a job
full ball he misses that three here's
Troy Brown jr. quickly up to Banga and
Martha that should have been a goaltend
you see Bob had a position actually that
might have been that's going down it's a
built in I can't see Chris
I can't see Chris he don't care about
speed or vertical nothing all Chris
talks about is the lake now I will say
this so coaches Major League Baseball
starts this weekend and an NBA back and
I think the commissioners done a an
admirable job getting everything
although yoga camp only did that a
little bit last year now hold for three
you know pitch there and he won't
encounter now you're kidding up and down
and you're getting up down five on five
not three on three or four on four but I
like him
play and and here's why I think he will
even when they get into the seeding
games Chris yeah because he played nice
run here remembers tonight at seventy
nine ten straight points block area on
the whipped cream on the ice cream on
the cake six four hit him unofficially
exiled